[Music]  and Intuit our mission is the power  prosperity around the world especially  for those that need it most  prosperity takes many different forms  but during this global pandemic were  reminded not of our differences but how  much we share we all value health safety  community and security  that's why Intuit is committed resources  and funding to worldwide organizations  including the World Health Organization  to support the people who are on the  frontlines providing relief we're also  honored to support the European Union  Global coronavirus initiative we're all  in this thing together and intuitive's  proud to be doing its part to help  tackle the corner virus